[Music]
all right you guys welcome back let's
dive back into it we got seven or eight
more layouts to go let's go back in okay
stay motivated how do you stay motivated
and inspired I have a little problem
with the way this one reads but how to
or how do you isn't really important to
stay motivated and inspired I think we
need to connect those sentences a little
bit more and right now when you start
introducing a bunch of different point
sizes it becomes a little tricky so even
one headline she's using three point
sizes I think if you used two that would
be okay one would be okay too and so I
think this one probably needs a little
bit more help in terms of what the heck
happened here okay this one needs a
little bit more help because it's
supposed to read how do you stay
motivated and inspired okay so I'd like
to connect us either points eyes or in
color but the fact that the point size
is different and the color difference it
makes me like just read that and
inspired doesn't really make sense on
its own okay okay
and so also the fact that you've done
lowercase and then uppercase here I
don't know it's just there's too many
tricks happening here so you've done
three point sizes two colors and you've
done upper lower and three base lines
it's too many tricks going on okay it's
supposed to be one connected thought so
let's connect them and then all the
other stuff is just textural and it's
totally okay all right
how I became a graphic designer
okay
that's not supposed to be there okay and
that would wind up in the printed design
the house that's not supposed to be
there I think this is oddly place how I
became a graphic designer
this one the flow is not working for me
as well as the other ones and we still
have similar problems here with we're
trapped space okay this one's okay this
is a good cut this one not so good it's
gonna be difficult because it's cutting
across four letters and so to get them
all to line up it's tricky it's very
tricky I just don't like these don't all
feel connected to me I'm not quite sure
what's happening here okay you could
probably also decrease the letting the
space between these two lines a little
bit because I'm starting to see what you
guys want to be mindful of the negative
space that's created between things as
much as the things you're putting down
on the page so I'm there's no hard and
fast rule as far as I'm concerned but I
think this could have been closed up a
hair so that this becomes less of a
white shape and more that we're just
reading the black shapes generally
speaking when you have a lot of white
space in between it feels like it's
another design element so I would try to
figure out how to make this let me put
this in on how to make this part work
together okay
the future money talk pricing design
okay there's a little spacing issue here
to the first thing is I like the big
bold number three it's red and this is
the second read and that's the third
reader possibly this is I also like the
funny type spacing dollar spacing here
it's kind of uneven and there is really
no rule to it's just about the rhythm
and how it feels so you could take
something that's highly recognizable
like the word pricing or design by
increasing the letter spacing in between
each letter here you're almost creating
like a very complex puzzle or it's it's
like an illustration or a graphic device
when it in fact it's just a word so
you'll see this done in a lot of main
titles where they want to get fun or
have fun with the typography they'll
space that funky like this I quite like
that I think it would be nice to connect
this to something when you add vertical
lines like that it's begging me to do
something like here as an element even
if you did a plus sign there or a dot or
something to ranch that or link them
together but then it needs to line up
with that so now that I see this I think
I need to move this down here so it
matches the baseline let's say you added
a red cross there or something can you
see how that that would tie this design
together and you you may not be aware of
it as the audience but you feel those
things okay and I like this is very
textural it's almost like you put a
little rubber stamp and you're cloning
little bits in there but here's the part
where I'm saying a lot of spacing or
line spacing isn't quite right you try
to do that a little bit more accurately
okay I'm not saying that's super
accurate but I feel like
is it the same I can't tell because my
marker is so fat but we want to just
make sure I still feel like this could
be tightened up okay so here's what I'm
gonna suggest we do let me tell you all
that stuff I can't oh I can't do it
right now I'll show you guys on the
internet what I mean if we take this is
gonna mess up the design a little bit
but if we inched it up a little bit less
you I ain't [ __ ] up too far come on
okay so this becomes a group and that
becomes money top so it's not all just
even out or spacing you'll notice you
when the letting decreases this reads as
a package unit it comes together versus
one point two points and three points
okay it invests the power design but
actually created some opportunity for me
to share with you guys
possible and design thing oops okay that
sometimes we're focused mostly on
putting things down on the page like
this element and this element sometimes
it's cool to delete things and this is
just not intentional it's just because
we're working fast and dirty like that
sometimes you can create really cool
things by just taking things away if you
remember in old days you would print
things out you would tape them up or use
glue stick and sometimes with your
exacto blade you'd cut off corners and
your echo that's kind of cool or you can
shift the typography a little bit let me
show you what I mean by that now this is
gonna further destroy the design but you
see this angle right here if we
replicated that angle it's it like right
there more or less and we took this
design and we take and we shift it we
can create some interesting designs so
we're following that idea and we're just
shifting that now this needs to be your
normal because there's too many tricks
on the page and of course I would fix
this part but that's what we can do
there and then what you would do is on
this layer here you might add an element
Y you might add an element here to
reinforce that's not the right angle but
you might add a little element right
there that ties are designed together
okay so these are little visual tricks
that you can do to anchor all your
design it's a theme that you can hear me
talk about over and over again when it
comes to typography okay next one good
job a little tweak here and there you'll
remember all this right okay
101 things I learned in Business School
why does that zero look funny to me okay
I don't want things I learned in
business school pretty straightforward
layout and I see this kind of bugs me a
little bit that it's exact same element
copied over I think there needs to be a
theme and needs to be reoccurring but
I'd like for you to continue to find
variations on the theme and not use the
exact same type set that you borrowed
from that side okay I think it'd be nice
actually if you use some let's let's
switch inks here let me go default maybe
you use okay let's see if I can do this
here I'm gonna grab this copy here you
guys this one right here I'm gonna copy
and paste in front and I'm gonna move it
over here okay I'm gonna switch this
sucker to multiply so that you can see
it V I'm gonna move it around and maybe
I'll make it more transparent I would
love to see some other kinds of themes
exploration and this is one one way to
do it I just probably not always but
maybe you take that and you maybe make
it smaller I don't know but you can
repeat the type
oops and then you can repeat it again if
you wanted to its aren't gonna get a
little bit messy here I'm just trying to
think I'm on my feet here imagine if the
red parts weren't there we don't have to
use the same elements over and over and
again I'd like to see a little bit more
variety
okay I told him mess up the design but I
think the Internet
gets it right yeah okay again too much
lighting you can see there's just too
much and we just tighten it up about 20
30 % there 101 numbers are a great
element to work with this 101 so if we
were going back to your original design
here if I were to delete this sucker
okay and we typed in 101 let me show you
how that would look it's not going to
work because I don't have enough layers
to work with her 101 and we use Tora
yeah we made a bowl why do I have bowled
I've used the other Fedora can you
select it from pot I can't go down more
there's two for tourists you had that
one their Pole right there okay and I'm
gonna make it white
okay it's like this you can have tea
made that sucker really really big
so my rule is if you're gonna introduce
a new point size make sure it's at least
double or half the other size that's
gonna give you a maximum contrast so you
could have easily put 101 behind this
type and bring this type in front of it
or play around with it so let me hide
this so you guys can see what's going on
okay you can play around with it maybe
make it a little bit bigger so it cuts
off that edge there so I'm a mindful of
how it's cut off here on line fold how
it's cut there and set good strong
shapes you can bring this type forward
okay it's just some options numbers and
and characters like the ampersand any
other thing that you can do to break up
the typography because we stopped
recognizing as words and we see as
symbols and graphics I think make it
easier for us and in terms giving us
different variety of things to work with
maybe that's not the right size what do
you think maybe like that size maybe
that's a little bit better
it could be ginormous too you could try
that it's hard for us to look at because
there's so much stuff I can't work with
here but that's that's an idea of
direction to go down
let's keep looking at things
okay this is a picture of Jose this is a
good image good photograph an image
within an image within an image I like
that those are usually pretty nice
tricks to play with and then you have
this kind of transparency overlay which
I like is that a box that's within the
image
it's at the focal point yeah that part
bugs me but there's not much you can do
you could clone it out but how to be a
designer theoretically that's the center
yes does it look Center to you Emily why
isn't it looks headed to me I think
because I'm over here it looks enter
into you okay
I'm gonna embarrass myself one more time
and I'm gonna do where is it oh you
already created layer for me let's just
try let's just try do this right and
every time I do this Emily gets a weak
in the knees
all right okay so I'm going to merge
that down which is command e to merge it
down and I'm hitting number 3 - so hey
just hunter huh what do you think this
is Emily I know what it is for me
personally I'm bothered by this part
that this seems a lot smaller than this
but maybe you're right I think it's
because of this and like the cola yeah
yeah so so far emily has corrected for
the ways of her pass so far and I think
I have one or two more opportunities to
prove her wrong let's see the designers
dilemma integrity versus profitability
there's a future okay
there's some summer screen refresh issue
there yeah it's called a ghosting that's
ghosting let's go see my hair fix it oh
it's just burnt in this aren't you the
only owner of this thing yeah I'm gonna
blame the monitor no it is the monitor I
would you just leave your screen on burn
shoot okay retina monitor scaling on us
okay first of all let's make sure that
we point this out
what is this call that's called an
apostrophe as opposed to a prime mark
which is this okay you guys most
typesetting programs will automatically
switch it out for you but make sure you
learn the difference between that I'm
sorry versus this there's an apostrophe
that's a prime mark this is flipped 36
feet that's what you use okay okay so
good on that designer dilemma integrity
versus profitability I don't love that
this is here this is relating to nothing
I think it's nice that use you indent
this so this is a nice way to create
variety in the typeset so you have
designers dilemma that's a group and
then you indent this part integrity
versus profitability without changing
the point size without changing the
color with that changing of upper versus
lower case that's working really well
what's not working really well is this
part right and I think you did that
because it does it chop off over there
on the right hand side okay so her
instinct said pushes over here so it
doesn't get cut off on this side what
would have been better if you just line
those two up and scale the whole
typography the point sizes down so you
have enough breathing room on both sides
that's it this layout is pretty simple
I you know we have similar issues with
these overlapping look at this one right
here look at that because there's so
many of these yeah you know what you can
do you can do it behind it you don't
always have to do in front of it there's
lots of tricks you can do and it's your
own design and your own problem to solve
this one is missing some detail will
refer to this as a mouse type right
where if you had a little mouse type
let me see here here and here it would
give you a little detail we need
something in this layout to give you
detail so I'm gonna give you guys a tip
here okay if you were to have a grid so
you don't have to have any more
typography elements I'm gonna quickly
create a grid here and I know it's not
perfect you guys just relax it'll be
okay I'm just eyeballing the spacing oh
that's okay and then the computers
fighting me on that because there wasn't
snap to some kind of thing let's assume
that's a that's an okay great I almost
like this again I'm gonna copy and I'll
paste that I'm gonna command T it rotate
this 90 degrees right I'm gonna put this
down I'm gonna move it over a little bit
let's just say it's like that okay so
let me go back to this hit come in each
I merge those two layers command D to
deselect anything hit me and they had
four or five or two to control the
transparency if you add some fine grid
lines this is not a fine grid language
you use a 1/2 a point point five points
of a grid line you can create some
interesting complexity out of nothing
without introducing any more typography
without making it anything else for us
to read this is the the push and pull of
design and what a graphic designer can
do so if your layout is too simple add
something to it if it's too complicated
take things away that's the rule okay so
this one is lacking for a little detail
and there's some weird choppy bits but
you guys can see now if you add in a
simple grid which we did and the grid
doesn't have to look like this check
this out you guys remember how we talked
about be mindful what you add and you
can also be taking things away so you
could have done something like that and
that would look good right maybe it's
too long or maybe it's too thick just
delete that clean that up so it's nice
and clean so you can do things like that
you can also take this and you can
offset it it doesn't have to be on the
same grid anymore and that will still be
okay so some things for Emily to think
about to try I think it'll make for a
more interesting design I hope you guys
think the same thing let's keep going
who put that scribble on there oh oh
that's okay it's okay well I can fix it
fast I drop that and then Marquis and
option delete I'm using a lot of
keyboard shortcut guys Emily knows a
bunch I know a few and it's good that
you have to learn your keyboard
shortcuts you work faster you think
quicker and you want to be able to
explore ideas this is what I'm talking
about when I say master the tools learn
all the keyboard shortcuts so you work
at the speed of thought okay this is a
really nice layout type PO graphi I
think that's okay ah here's a problem
here's a problem I do not like the two
dashes here so we can cheat okay
christos is cheap not on your girlfriend
not in your boyfriend but you can cheat
on your layout so this is where grammar
and English says you have to do it like
this but it's much better if you took
this layout and you move it over here
okay and you put the dash on this side
even me doing this actually makes the
layout kind of interesting to me that
there's a little element of
unexpectedness and here's what I might
say to you guys sometimes when you work
with a vector program like Adobe
Illustrator or InDesign you don't have
these moments of cutting and moving
things around so I like to think about
physical media even though I'm working
in digital space that if this were a
piece of paper or a piece of Ruby live I
had to cut and move things around you
get some interesting happy accidents and
don't be afraid to explore that okay so
why I take the same it's it's so hidden
okay if I were to take this same unit of
measure and I hit the letter M for the
marquee tool I'm gonna move it over here
holding it on shift key and if I took
this and I offset that a little bit to
repeat that element and you can see it
add some visual interest and it's
breaking up the space now why the heck
would I do that
and I'll tell you why right now because
see I see Emily cut this off here which
breaks up the border in her other design
the borders been well respected and she
didn't touch it by doing that I think I
have now permission
break other borders and it creates some
kind of visual interest I think we might
have just lucked out Emma let's see we
have what do you think did we luck out
you know you know where I'm going with
this
so did we luck out so close so you can
see that even in an accident and cutting
this we want to make everything relate
and this is the power of the grid you
guys this is where you make the design
sing and I also believe you could move
this over there it would be a really
strong okay because this is such a
well-established grid line already that
moving this sucker no respect suckers
I'm just gonna move this guy over here
assuming that's correct
I'm hit B for brush o or I'm sorry
option to pick the color and then M to
Marquita and then hit option delete and
fill that to fix that thing okay now if
we hide this because the line becomes
part of design it's kind of interesting
right it's something that's happening
here and I think it's kind of cool so we
broke a rule we didn't need to add the -
if we if we just use that just to fill
the space and it's a little bit
unexpected it breaks the grid line a
little bit this one has nice detail has
big graphic elements and it has a good
bold headline typography it's pretty
cool and you've got the OCR a typeface
in there or sometimes referred to as
okra which I love okra okay awesome job
guys I hope you enjoyed another edition
of typography with Emily Shay and myself
we went over 16 designs in about one
week
using the most popular episodes as a
premise to create a series of 16 posters
to create a grid of four by four and
that's it for now let us know if you
guys liked it hit that subscribe button
and see you guys on the next apocrypha
video